[Musik]
die ecotel de lausanne gehört zu den
renommiertesten handels schulen für die
hotelindustrie 2800 studenten aus über
110 nationen streben an der ehl nach
exzellenz können uns selbstbewusstsein
wir begleiten drei studenten im
vorbereitungsjahr und zwei am ende ihres
studiums
[Musik]
alexander schal er 18 jahre alt mit
seiner matura in der tasche geht er in
das vorbereitungsjahr immer bitte ist 21
sie wurde in der genferseeregion geboren
und beginnt ihr studium an dieser
internationalen schule genau wie alex
119 jahre alt der sohn eines hoteliers
geht mit selbstvertrauen ins erste
semester annina von falkenstein mit 21
beginnt sie ihre vorletzte studienjahr
die junge bärin strebt nach nichts
weniger als exzellenz auf rebecca 27
startet sein letztes semester der
energetische afr möchte selbständiger
unternehmer werden
[Musik]
letztes mal in der hotelfachschule
letzte prüfung für fremdsein studenten
business project er beginnt mit seinem
team ein firmen restaurant für die
kantonale versicherung zu planen
alexander ist nicht gut drauf und er hat
auch nicht die richtige einstellung
ich habe ein bisschen das gefühl dass
ihnen der respekt fehlt der respekt vor
den lehrpersonen aber auch gegenüber den
mädchen land das ist frech und
unprofessionell
außerdem hat er eine schwierige
entscheidung treffen müssen es ist
unglaublich schwer für mich aber meine
zukunft ist hier an der ehl und nicht
beim volleyball immer leidet immer mehr
an ihre schulter
ich habe starke schmerzen das fängt hier
an und steigt nach oben
trotz der schmerzen muss sie während der
von der schule organisierten jobmesse
ein praktikum für ihr zweites semester
finden
alex entdeckt die freuden der raumpflege
zimmerservice die ekel mich an ich frage
mich was die machen sauberkeit ist ihnen
egal
achtung es sollte gleich klingen bei
ihnen was benutzen sie für die toilette
und was für den rest auf der fahrt nach
basel nutzt annina die zeit um für ihre
prüfungen zu lernen
sie ist glücklich für ein wochenende das
gemütliche familiennest zu genießen
[Musik]
los gehts mein letzter schultag die
letzte präsentation
ich spüre den druck es wird schon
schiefgehen
hier werden wir die präsentation
abhalten
der saal ist lea wir haben die
möglichkeit ihn zu dekorieren um ein
gutes bild abzugeben
wir wollen nun die dinge die wir
benötigen um den saal vorzubereiten
für frieden und sein team steht heute
die große herausforderung an
sie vertreten ihr projekt für die
kantonale versicherung die sie mit einem
beratungsmandat beauftragt hat im rahmen
ihrer diplomarbeit des berühmten
studenten business projekts bei diesem
entscheidenden auftritt zählt jedes
detail natürlich der inhalt aber auch
die kunst der präsentation um viertel
vor acht werden die kunden kommen
wir werden sie begrüßen und mit ihnen
einen kaffee trinken dann werden wir
unsere präsentation abhalten
wir werden hier vorne stehen wenn wir
fertig sind verlassen wir den saal und
später werden sie uns zurückrufen um uns
mitzuteilen ob wir bestanden haben
dann werden wir wissen ob wir die ehl
abschließen oder nicht
so selten sehr frühen stunde einige
stockwerke tiefer alex ist ihm
kochworkshop mission des tages walker
mole zubereiten mit freude und guter
laune
ich sage mir einfach wir haben nur noch
3 wochen kurs
wir hatten seit anfang jahr keine ferien
das geht so nicht die tomaten müssen
dreimal so klein sein
ok-chef hast du dich heute morgen nicht
rasiert keine gnade für haare die die
schlechte angewohnheit haben jeden tag
nach zu wachsen
der student hat 15 minuten zeit sich zu
rasieren und in die küche zurück zu
gehen
[Musik]
der tag erwacht und afri macht eine
kleine pause um seinen stress abzubauen
wird der campus fehlen ja klar schon
seit vier jahren bin ich hier dass er
mich geprägt ist ja noch nicht fertig es
bleiben noch zwei stunden
fertig nichts vergessen oft denkt sogar
daran den raum zu parfümieren
das riecht ja gut werden kunden dozenten
und prüfer den geruch bemerken möglich
aber sie werden sich sicher besonders
auf das konzept konzentrieren dass die
studentengruppe erarbeitet hat alexandra
wird eine prüfung ablegen er hat keinen
stress nehmt euch zeit beruhigt euch
wenn ihr fertig seid könnt ihr euch auf
sozialen netzwerken tummeln
aber vermeidet lauter fragen denn die
anderen arbeiten
kein lahm die studierenden haben 20
minuten zeit um die fragen zu
beantworten
am ende jedes workshops werden
theoretische branchenkenntnisse geprüft
anhand von multiple choice fragebögen
auf einem tablett nach fünf minuten ist
alexandra fertig als erster das war
guetta spiel
die fragen betrafen die theorie dass er
überhaupt nicht schwierig alles mit ein
bisschen logik zu beantworten
für andere scheint es nicht so einfach
zu sein
konzentration während der erlaubten 20
minuten alle ausloggen nutzt euer tablet
und schaltet es aus legst du meinst
zurück beruhen denn mach einfach so lieb
man kann am schluss die antworten sehen
aber das mache ich nie ich warte lieber
auf das endresultat
und bestätigst du na ja ich hätte mir
lernen können aber das wird schon
aufregen und sein team kommen von ihrer
präsentation
[Musik]
ich denke die präsentation war spitze es
ist cool wir sind stolz auf uns jetzt
warten wir auf das feedback um zu
erfahren was sie von unserer
präsentation halten
aber ich denke es ist gut gelaufen
[Musik]
alptraum hinter den kulissen der koch
des commerce shops bewertet jeden
schüler wie gehts super
wie war die woche die küche hat mir sehr
viel spaß gemacht er nicht an die wand
lehnen entschuldigung wie schätzen sie
sich selbst ein
was war diese woche positiv ich fand die
rezepte interessant ist
ich habe vieles dazugelernt etwas das
sie nicht gut gemacht haben vielleicht
die konzentration
damit bin ich einverstanden
sie arbeiten gut das steht außer frage
das problem sobald sie mit einer arbeit
fertig sind
verhalten sie sich wie ein kleinkind ich
mag dass sie es untereinander gut haben
manchmal gibt es ja auch streit in der
küche ich habe gehört sie haben zuvor
noch nie gearbeitet
nein noch nie ok jetzt werden sie in ein
praktikum starten
dort wird es um einiges strenger sie
werden bezahlt daher muss immer alles
perfekt sein
also gewöhnen sie sich daran vielen dank
für diese woche soll ich wen rufen
bringen sie mir
die beratung der jury hinter
verschlossenen türen ist beendet die mit
spannung erwartete entscheidung fällt
die mitglieder der jury bestehend aus
unseren partnern und klienten und ihrem
coach teilen ihnen gerne mit dass sie
brillant und mit erfolg bestanden haben
wir wünschen ihnen zukünftig viel glück
in ihrer karriere
glückwünsche jetzt wird gefeiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine mutter gratuliert allen
[Musik]
annina ist fleißig die prüfungen hatten
bereits am dienstag angefangen ich habe
noch dieses wochenende um mich auf
nächste woche vorzubereiten mich
erwarten fünf prüfungen innert vier
tagen
es ist ein wenig stressig und die oft
zusammen
nein gar nicht
normalerweise arbeiten wir nicht so
zusammen weil wir nicht wirklich auf
demselben niveau sind
ich sag lieber nicht mehr weiter ist
normalerweise kann ich seine fragen
beantworten ich lerne auswendig das gibt
mir sicherheit
er ließ das ein- oder zweimal durch und
kombiniert in seinem kopf für ihn ist es
einfacher annina strebt eine besondere
erwähnung an exzellenz steht im
mittelpunkt ich arbeite gern für die
schule und möchte als studentin gute
leistungen bringen
ich bin sehr ambitioniert und setzte
mehr hohe ziele
deshalb hätte ich das auch gerne in
meinem diplom vermerkt
und ihre deutschschweizer mitbewohner
ermutigen sie ein echter fan club
[Musik]
was ist denn mit einer tür passiert
ich kam rein war genervt und hab dann
ein bisschen dampf abgelassen
wieso hast du so genervt dummheiten
ich werde eine neue türe kaufen müssen
400 franken der fall ist ein liebesleben
nun denkbar hier im 2er zimmer nicht
undenkbar man muss sich organisieren
ich habe meinem zimmerkollegen eine
nachricht geschickt unter männern
versteht man sich alexandra wechselt
sein hemd und das aus gutem grund er
wird wegen seines verhaltens zu einem
disziplinarrat vorgeladen
ich glaube ich habe es verkackt hallo
ich bin zuständig für studenten belange
im akademischen bereich
wir kennen uns ja schon ich bin
verantwortlich für das vorbereitungsjahr
sie wissen im vorbereitungsjahr bezieht
sich die hälfte der noten auf
sozialkompetenz verhalten respekt
gegenüber den dozenten
leider sind ihre noten in diesem bereich
sehr tief weil ihr verhalten überhaupt
nicht den werten der schule entspricht
wenn ich die kommentare lese habe ich
das gefühl wir sind hier im club
méditerranée oder in einer ferienwohnung
doch vor uns sind sie ganz anders mister
sehr perfekt führen sich gut auf dies
ist doppelgesicht von klassenclown und
gentleman muss aufhören
am freitag erwartet sie eine wichtige
koch prüfung mit 30 punkten
wir erwarten ein tadelloses verhalten
ich habe gehört dass sie beim kochen in
34 minuten fertig sind und dann relaxen
nutzen sie die zeit
auch wenn sie fünf minuten länger
brauchen kann das einen unterschied
machen ein praktikum wird ein solches
verhalten nicht toleriert und schädigt
den ruf unserer schule
[Applaus]
ich denke es ist wegen dem volleyball
und all dem das vorbereitungsjahr ist
auch ein wenig langweilig sind in der
küche von 7.30 bis 20 uhren müssen jeden
tag die gleichen jobs machen
ich denke alles wird gut
ich muss mich nur ein wenig
zusammenreißen und das ganze ein wenig
ernster nehmen
[Musik]
sie sind nicht rasiert aber ich nein das
ist kein männerverein bad wie dieser
oder keiner muss ich mich jetzt rasieren
ja unbedingt bis gleich adlerauge arias
mission lorang wacht über den look der
dresscode gilt von 7 uhr morgens bis 19
während dieser zeit bin ich auf dem
campus und überwache das verhalten und
die kleidung die wir erwarten
sein hemd ihn aus seiner hose
grenzwertig gibt es eine gelbe karte
nein bei mir gibt es selten gelbe karten
ich habe sie zwar immer dabei aber die
sind eher für schlechtes verhalten und
schlechte kommunikation wenn sich ein
schüler an der bar schlecht benimmt und
unangebrachtes vokabular los dann gibt
es eine gelbe oder rote karte
aber die benutze ich sehr sehr selten
sie haben die prüfung beendet ja ich
habe einiges verwechselt aber egal
achtung der rock ist ein wenig kurz
mission ist super das ist wichtig aber
ich mache das immer diskret
ich könnte ja sagen verlassen sie das
gebäude nein ich will eher konstruktiv
sein
ich habe immer mein tablet dabei da sind
alle details zum dresscode mit
beispielen wie man sich anziehen soll
mit dieser unterstützung kann ich die
studierenden an die professionelle
erscheinung und den dresscode erinnern
ein schönes beispiel für einen
gepflegten bart genau so muss er sein
wenn sie müde sind dann gehen sie nach
hause hier wird nicht geschlafen
[Musik]
es tut mich kein musik hören und ich
habe eine stunde zeit für mich danach
geht es mir besser
trotz ihrer schmerzen in schulter ist es
für immer wichtig in form zu bleiben
es geht langsam besser ich habe viel
physiotherapie gemacht übungen für die
halsmuskeln so konnte ich meine schulter
ein wenig stabilisieren
aber seither habe ich zu wenig trainiert
ich habe früher viel getanzt modern
klassisch ich bin geschwommen und habe
zwei jahre die uci zu gemacht und mich
dabei am hals verletzt seit der
verletzung mache ich fitness hier achten
alle sehr auf ihr äußeres die lehrer
sagen uns unser aussehen ist wie eine
visitenkarte
also macht man sich immer gedanken
darüber
und wenn man fit ist ist das bestimmt
ein weiterer vorteil
ich mache gern sport habe aber keine
model figur
der dresscode ist anspruchsvoll wenn man
klein und etwas rundlich ist das ist
eine weitere motivation für mich sport
zu treiben
[Musik]
für alex beginnen die letzten workshop
worden
dieses mal macht er sich ein sushi die
stundenpläne sind voll die müdigkeit
macht sich bemerkbar
man hat an dieser schule nicht viel zeit
für sich man muss sich persönlich sehr
engagieren man ist immer hier und dort
und man steht immer das ist schon hart
du kommst aus dem kurs und hast du nur
wenig freizeit musst du abends viel
lernen nein eigentlich gar nicht das ist
ein vorteil dieser schule alles ist
praxis wir müssen nicht irgend welche
hausaufgaben machen oder lektüre
erledigen klar theorie büffeln
ich habe mich geschnitten chef tief
arme alex die krankenschwester kümmert
sich um einen ernsteren fall er muss
seinen schmerz geduldig ertragen
arbeit im morgengrauen in der bäckerei
alexandra und seine kollegen bereiten
brötchen croissants und anderes gebäck
zu für die gesamte schule nachdem er zur
ordnung gerufen wurde ist er heute
unauffällig fleißig und fokussiert es
ist die zielgerade vor dem praktikum
da fast alle gehen weg ich habe einen
kumpel der nach london geht der andere
geht nach paris er bleibt die 2g nach
bali oder paris viele gehen schaut so
macht man das
alexandra hat sich erst in letzter
minute bemüht ein praktikum zu finden er
hofft es in einem luxushotel in bila
machen zu können dass sein vater führt
aber dieser idee läuft gefahr nicht
akzeptiert zu werden da die schulordnung
das praktikum in einem eigenen
familienbetrieb verbietet hast du einen
plan b habe ich nicht keine ahnung ich
habe keinen bock ein neues praktikum zu
suchen das ist kompliziert wir werden
sehen
ein problem dass alexandre später am tag
lösen möchte ich muss zum studium der
fans büro und mit den verantwortlichen
zu reden
vielen dank
ist nicht sehr tief nur desinfizieren
ich muss weiter arbeiten
passiert so was oft in der küche gibt es
viele unfälle viele verbrennungen
es ist heiß in die küche die
schülerarbeiten lange sie schauen auf
die professorin
irgendwann ist man nicht mehr
konzentriert und wenn man bis spät
abends gefeiert oder gelernt hat und
müde ist geht es schnell
der verband sollte nicht nass werden
sonst kommen sie wieder damit kein
feuchtes warmes klima für infektionen
entsteht ist das gut für sie schönen tag
es ist nicht tief aber es hat ziemlich
geblutet
du hast meinen finger da rein
ja das geht die arbeit geht weiter mit
weniger geschicklichkeit
mittagspause für alexandra der danach
einen termin hat um über sein praktikum
zu sprechen
ich werde schauen ob ich mein praktikum
war mein vater machen kann
ein bisschen verhandeln ich werde
einfach sagen dass ich in den ferien
schon dort gearbeitet und mich im team
wohl gefühlt habe im reglement steht
dass dies nicht erlaubt ist aber ich
hoffe es wird akzeptiert folgen sie mir
und er hat gesagt dass es auf keinen
fall möglich sei das reglement ist für
alle das gleiche
jetzt muss ich halt noch ein praktikum
finden ein definitiver entscheid
ich habe mir meine argumente dargelegt
aber es gibt keine weitere diskussion
ich habe noch einen ganzen monat zeit
bis die praktika beginnen
ich werde 1 finden
[Musik]
auf regen ist seinen eltern massiv und
bett ihr sehr verbunden geblieben
sprecht ihr immer albanisch ja auch mit
meinem bruder mit allen die albanisch
sprechen spreche ich albanisch so
verstehen uns die schweizer nicht
dieses bett bekam ich mit 16
ein rundes bett ich wollte unbedingt
blaue wände ein völliger blödsinn
das war ich mit 2 mein onkel hat das
gemalt seine bilder sind überall im haus
er malt immer noch im kosovo das ist
auch von ihm das hiesige schloss ließ
und malst du auch da war ich acht jahre
alt da sich das gemalt habe
ich weiß nicht war es schwierig für die
kosten der schule aufzukommen
es war schon hart aber ich habe in
meiner frau diskutiert
wenn die motivation da ist dann ist
alles gerechtfertigt auf riems eltern
kamen als politische flüchtlinge 1988 in
die schweiz
was ist das da oben das war mein freund
wir waren zusammen im gefängnis er wurde
von der serbischen polizei umgebracht
wurde im krieg 89 woher kannten sie
wir waren zusammen im gefängnis wegen
demonstrationen
er hieß auch afri deshalb nannte ich
meinen sohn achim um ihn zu ehren die
mutter wie auch der vater von afrika
hatten hochschulen besucht in medizin
und wirtschaft hier haben sie von vorne
angefangen
ich habe bei coop gearbeitet nach und
nach haben sie ihr studium wieder
aufgenommen
neben der arbeit ihren abschluss gemacht
und ihre kinder groß gezogen
ich war schon als ja mit 35 war es
schwierig mit den jungen mitzuhalten
in 20 jährigen sie sollten über meine
eltern einen film machen statt über die
ehl
[Musik]
zum dienstende geht immer auf dem
zahnfleisch einen kaffee bitte aus
seinen kaffee um wach zu bleiben bis sie
fertig um 99 oder halb sehen was machst
du heute abend nach hause gehen oder
trainieren oder ausgehen
ich weiß es noch nicht mal schauen ob
ich fit bin und nicht so stark nach
fritteuse rieche ja dann kaffee was hast
du heute vor weiß ich noch nicht so
werden es ja sehen
ich bin freitag und samstag ausgegangen
ich habe nicht viel geschlafen morgen
beginne ich um halb sieben
das ist aber früh immer williams bass in
den beliebtesten club in lausanne für
studenten
warst du im fitnessstudio nein ich bin
schließlich duschen gegangen
ich konnte einfach nicht mehr heute war
ein anstrengender tag
ich mach morgen fitness wenn ich nicht
zu müde bin jeden montag gibt es für die
ehl eine spezielle party im bass in
lausanne zu werden wir hingehen ich bin
das ganze jahr nicht im bus gewesen
heute ist die zweitletzte chance also
werde ich heute zum letzten mal ging bei
alexandra wird champagner getrunken und
zwar richtig konnte auf die werte der
ehl heute abend gehe ich aus frische
luft tapetenwechsel ein bisschen
rumblödeln in der stadt man ist in
meinem zimmer auf dem campus dem food
court das wird langweilig die abende
hier sind nix man ist die ganze woche
hier das essen ist viel zu teuer auf dem
campus 30 franken
du wirst viel aber jemand der normal ist
ich nehme immer zwei portionen
ich hole mir zwei steaks es zählt wie
ein mensch mit dessert und einem getränk
kostet das 30 35 franken ich finde das
übertrieben und das zweimal täglich das
problem ist es gibt hier keinen laden in
der nähe
man muss in die stadt nach lausanne das
ist 25 minuten entfernt
man braucht eine stunde nur um nudeln zu
kaufen
wir dürfen im zimmer keine toaster oder
mikrowelle haben wir müssen also
zwingend hier essen
nachdem vorbereitungsjahr werden wir
unsere eigene wohnung haben unser leben
wird sich ändern
jetzt gehen wir was trinken
diejenigen die sich leisten können
fahren mit dem taxi in die stadt runter
emma und ihre mitbewohnerin nehmen den
bus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die seriöse annina ist in budapest vor
vier tagen habe ich meine letzten
prüfungen geschrieben
ich denke es ist eher gut gelaufen
[Musik]
ich werde die resultate aber erst im
februar erhalten
dann kann ich sagen ob es wirklich gut
gelaufen ist oder ob das nur mein gefühl
ist natürlich ist da nina nicht zum
sightseeing in ungarn
sie ist von der ehl ausgewählt worden
als hostess für eine internationale
konferenz über hotel investitionen an
nina und ihre freundin haben das glück
im prestigeträchtigen luxus hotel zu
übernachten in dem die konferenz am
nächsten tag beginnt willkommen im
kempinski unserer bescheidenen bleibe
folgen sie mir das ist ein nina und mike
was mein wir kommen zu hause auf bruder
fest das ist das beste von annina das
ist schon mit pizza nase auch sehr
aufregend
das ist meins 100 prozent höher auf
keine kissenschlacht habt ihr
zusätzliche kissen bestellt hat online
recherchiert und ein kissen menü
gefunden sie will jetzt jeden abend alle
kisten testen
ein kleiner snack und dann ins bett denn
ein langer tag kündigt sich an
[Musik]
es ist der große tag für afrika aber
auch für seine eltern und seinen bruder
die zur diplomübergabe und
abschlussfeier kommen
wir werden jetzt alle reden anhören es
wird sicher emotional
alexander ist heute für die dauer der
feierlichkeiten in service momentan sind
werden da bis 16 uhr 45 also eineinhalb
stunden
heute abend werden wir an der bar
champagner servieren bis 22 uhr
endlich ist es soweit eure diplomfeier
wir feiern heute euren erfolg
herzlichen glückwunsch an alle wissen
sie was zu tun ist alles abräumen und
neue tassen servieren genau immer alles
nachfüllen alles schön abräumen wissen
sie wie die kaffeemaschine funktioniert
man ist hier genug wasser drin
nein ich gehe aufhört winter genug
tassen genau jetzt sollte alles klar
sein
macht nicht alle alles zur selben zeit
wer macht was in 20 minuten seid ihr
fertig wasser ist im backoffice
die angestellten haben uns gesagt sein
spitzname sei speedy gonzales
er ist sehr schnell nehmen sie alles auf
einmal die gläser die tassen
es ist wichtig dass sie lernen
selbständig zu arbeiten und die
initiative zu ergreifen um alles schön
anzurichten
finden sie dass sie gut aus sie und ihre
arbeitskollegen können zufrieden sein
bedanken sie sich bei pullin und marie
sie haben ihnen geholfen immer bedanken
annina wird aktiv in budapest jetzt hat
die arbeit begonnen
es ist gut denn wenn man arbeitet
vergeht die zeit schneller hier habe ich
die kleinen namensschilder für die
registrierung sie sind alphabetisch
geordnet so geht es am schnellsten über
das ganze gesicht strahlend begrüßt sie
die teilnehmer investoren und mitglieder
der großen hotelketten das speed netz
fragen beginnt in fünf minuten links am
ende des flurs wir freuen uns sie dort
zu sehen
danke
sieht aus wie ein business gespräch
ich hab nicht unterbrochen ich schon ich
nicht du musst bist du sicher ja willst
du nein du gehst annina überwindet ihre
schüchternheit und wagte es die
diskussion zu unterbrechen
an der hhl sind alle damit beschäftigt
das bankett für die absolventen und
ihrer familien vorzubereiten
alexandra ist konzentriert arbeitet
effizient er weiß man behält ihn im auge
die zahl steht er lang ersehnte moment
bevor die diplomfeier wir überreichen
das diplom für den bachelor der
wissenschaft des internationalen
gastgewerbe managements und das diplom
der fachhochschule westschweiz für
hotellerie und gastgewerbe berufe
unter den bewundernden blick seiner
familie betritt die szene
[Applaus]
[Musik]
glücklich und auch traurig freunde zu
verlassen aber es ist natürlich cool
[Musik]
annina beendet ihren langen tag
ich bin sehr sehr müde
ich weiß nicht warum aber es war
spannend ich konnte in den saal und
eines mitverfolgen
das war sehr interessant für mich an der
ehl kündigt sich ein heißer abend an ein
sehr heißer ein mega fest der
verkleidung erwartet die absolventen die
geladenen kommen durch die gärten gab es
damals schon ticketschalter auf riems
leibwächter seine kumpel aus dem
quartier in dem er aufgewachsen ist und
die alle mit ihm die ehl begonnen haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und während dieser zeit gewesen in der
küche die party wird vollständig von den
studenten organisiert
[Musik]
highlight des abends die preise die sich
die absolventen selbst verleihen
zuerst das hübscheste paar
[Applaus]
leute ihr seid alle an unserer hochzeit
eingeladen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die ist unter
dann derjenige der die meisten mädchen
des vorbereitungs jahres verführt hat
sein name ist afrika
[Applaus]
ich weiß wirklich nicht wovon er redet
leute ehrlich aber können wir einen
richtigen der ehl würdigen tost
aussprechen
seid ihr bereit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nächstes mal in der hotelfachschule wir
empfehlen ihnen schon jetzt ein dessert
zu erstellen
das geht in ordnung man sagt nicht dass
geht man braucht selbstvertrauen
herzlichen glückwunsch an die gruppe
[Applaus]
hab dich lieb wir präsentieren das in
zürich und nicht an der schule das heißt
es später und unterarmen und um die
moral ibc nervös ich habe es nicht
absichtlich gemacht chef
wir reisen nach thailand all inclusive
ein phantastisches angebot das gibt es
nicht im reisebüro
[Musik]
ich hoffe das schwimmbecken hat 28 grad
sonst gibt es ärger
[Musik]